My husband's palette for authentic Mexican
food is on the level of my quest for 24 seven
nutrient dense
real foods.
And I'm okay with that because it makes me better in the kitchen.
Tonight I'm making him caldo do this.
A beef and vegetable soup with a rich meat broth.
I start by searing chunks of 100% grass fed beef on all sides.
I made sure to include bones
because they contain so many minerals and nutrients collagen,
connective tissue,
protein, and bone marrow.
After adding several batches of meat and bones
to a stock pot of boiling water,
I deglaze the pan along with onion,
garlic, and broth and add all that good flavor back into the stock pot.
I let that simmer for a few hours
until the meat was falling off the bone,
then added chopped carrot,
potato, and large chunks of cabbage to the pot until just cooked.
And lastly organic corn which took no time.
While the caldo de RES finished cooking,
I prepared some tortillas the fast way
using dried masa with a bit of hot water.
A tortilla
press is a great tool to have when pumping out homemade tortillas
and they only take a few minutes to fully cook in a hot coma.
I keep them warm and soft until dinner by storing them in a tortillero
while my family sits for dinner at the dining table.
I plate each bowl by carefully adding beef chunks,
each vegetable, a cabbage chunk,
And garnishing with pickled radish,
probiotic crowd and dried cilantro flowers from last year's garden.
This meal was nutrient dense and satisfied us all.